je suis timide et je m'énerve facilement
nous êtres humains créant sans cesse de
la pensée la pensée utile de la pensée
inutile nous sommes une machine à
fabriquer de la pensée c'est comme une
machine à barbapapa dans lequel on
ajoute du sucre encore et encore et sa
tournée ça tourne ça gonfle et salons le
problème c'est qu'on croit
ce qu'on pense et qu'on est sûr que
c'est vrai on peut se créer de la pensée
inutiles comme je suis nul je suis pas à
la hauteur je vais pas y arriver
les autres sont meilleurs que moi il le
fait exprès elle aurait dû m'appeler
il s'intéresse pas à moi je suis grosse
en réalité la pensée n'est que de la
pensée elle n'a pas plus de valeur que
ça quand j'étais enfant disait que
j'étais timide alors là pensé que
j'avais créé dans ma tête basse et que
j'étais timide je rougis c'est avant
même qu'on m'adresse la parole je
pouvais passer des après midi entière
avec des amis sans ouvrir la bouche une
seule fois même quand ils me posaient
des questions
je tremblais à l'idée de devoir
m'exprimer évidemment j'étais timide et
puis à 18 ans j'ai déménagé et je me
suis dit les gens que j'ai rencontrés ne
connaissent pas cette étiquette de moi
j'avais donc la liberté de ne plus
penser que j'étais timide et j'ai décidé
je ne suis pas timide je n'ai plus
jamais été timide
aujourd'hui je parle pour mon métier
tous les jours en public
j'ai tout simplement arrêter de croire
cette pensée entre nous j'aurais pu
arrêter d'y croire sans déménager on
peut bouger
intérieurement sans bouger physiquement
c'est si simple par moment et si
compliqué parfois le mois dernier je me
suis retrouvé à créer de la pensée
inutile sur un sujet complètement anodin
heureusement mon mari était là il me dit
où nadine ce n'est que de la pensée
c'est mon histoire j'avais 15 ans ma
soeur ariane en avait 19 c'était une
jeune fille qui est pleine de vie
passionnée et puis un jour elle m'a
appelée et elle m'a dit comme ça de but
en blanc
nadine je vois des fraises partout sur
les affiches dans les livres dans les
boutiques dans le métro d'abord j'ai pas
vraiment prêté attention
et puis un jour elle me réveille en
pleine nuit est en crise d'angoissé et
elle me dit regarde nadine mon pull
regarde il ya des gens qui se sont
introduits dans la maison ils ont
transformé mon pull il était riche il
est devenu doux c'était le début de sa
maladie mentale le début de nombreux
événements douloureux violence
hospitalisation crise elle met du scotch
sur les fissures de peinture de sa
chambre pour éviter que des gens
introduisent des gas pour l'embêter
quelques mois plus tard elle met fin à
ses jours
ils m'ont histoires de vie ne s'arrête
pas là dix ans après le frère de mon
mari met fin à ses jours aussi alors que
pour lui tout semblait bien aller
c'est lourd je les ai vécu de cette
longueur
qu'est ce qui nous arrive cette affreuse
qui nous arrive comment on va s'en
sortir c'est horrible qu'est ce que
j'aurais pu faire qu'est ce que j'aurais
dû faire
à quoi vont ressembler les fêtes de
famille
je suis envahi de ses pensées j'aurais
pu continuer comme ça a créé de la barbe
à papa inutile à créer de la pensée
inutile pendant longtemps
et petit à petit un pas à la fois jeu
cette lourdeur jeu la transforme en
moteur et je comprends que mon pouvoir
sur ma pensée se joue dans des mini
actions de courage je suis inquiète pour
mes enfants je suis inquiète pour mes
élèves j'étais enseignante à l'époque je
souhaite les équipes et de tout ce qui
pourra favoriser une bonne santé mentale
on fait du sport pour entretenir notre
corps
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
entretenir notre santé mentale
alors on n'a pas tout pouvoir sur notre
santé mentale
on n'a pas tous pouvoir parce que
l'hérédité parce que l'éducation parce
que l'environnement bien sûr une
influence on n'a pas tous pouvoir aussi
parce que parfois faire seule c'est trop
difficile et on peut demander de l'aide
un ami un psy une personne de sa famille
plusieurs fois j'ai pas réussi à faire
seul plusieurs fois j'ai été au fond du
trou il ya dix ans une dépression le
seul pouvoir que j'avais c'était d'aller
chercher du soutien pour retrouver petit
à petit ce pouvoir alors si petit
soit-il on a toujours un peu de pouvoir
on a du pouvoir allons puiser dans ce
pouvoir c'est mon histoire
j'ai été prise d'une boulimie de livres
de formation de conférence et puis un
jour je suis tombé sur un livre la
discipline positive je les dévorer
j'avais trouvé la discipline positive
jeane manson et line l'autre c'est une
démarche pour être bien dans ses baskets
et bien avec les autres
elle est issue d'un psychiatre
autrichien qui a consacré sa vie à
donner des clés de bonne santé mentale
selon l'organisation mondiale de la
santé la santé mentale
c'est le fondement du bien-être d'un
individu et du bon fonctionnement d'une
communauté alors levez la main ceux qui
pensaient avoir un peu de pouvoir sur
leur santé mentale
ceux qui n'ont pas levé la main vous
rester avec moi les autres aussi alors
pourquoi parler de santé mentale parce
que dans le monde
aujourd'hui une personne sur quatre est
atteinte de maladie mentale
ces 25 sur 100 c'est un quart de cette
salle c'est quoi la maladie mentale on
pense bipolaire on pense qu'ils
offraient ni on pense troubles de la
personnalité
ce qu'on oublie c'est que la maladie
mentale c'est aussi la dépression
l'anxiété la phobie les addictions
alcool drogue cigarettes alimentation
écran une personne sur quatre
si c'est pas vous c'est quelqu'un de
votre entourage il faut le savoir
notre santé mentale c'est bien plus
qu'une histoire de maladie mentale
alors je vous donne une clé je rentre
chez moi après une dure journée je suis
fatigué je suis frustré j'ai un projet
qui est tombé à l'eau j'ai eu des
embouteillages
j'arrive dans la cuisine et qu'est ce
que je vois le goûter des enfants sur le
comptoir
la vaisselle dans l'évier les sacs qui
traînent dans l'entré jeu trébuche sur
une chaussure je bouillonne
j'arrive auprès de mes enfants dans une
pièce là aussi mal rangés ils sont
devant l'écran plutôt que de faire leurs
devoirs
d'après vous comment je m'adresse à vous
calmement
non non
je recrée dessus passablement enamel
enfin si je suis vraiment honnête j'ai
complètement perdu le contrôle mois le
dragon sort de la forêt et crache du feu
alors pour comprendre cette explosion je
vais vous expliquer comment ça se passe
dans notre cerveau c'est le modèle du
cerveau de daniel sigl docteur d'annecy
goal.com qui à modéliser le cerveau dans
la main donc la main représente le
cerveau les ondes devant le front cette
partie là c'est la moelle épinière
ici dans la paume de la main le tronc
cérébral partie intimement liée à la
partie limbique du cerveau dans lequel
il ya nos émotions colère joie tristesse
peur notre mémoire ancienne et nous
réaction de survie attaque fuite
sidération quand on rabat les doigts par
dessus c'est le cortex
c'est ce qui nous permet d'appréhender
le monde extérieur la pensée la raison à
ce niveau là et sur les ongles devant le
cortex préfrontal dans lequel on à la
moralité l'empathie la capacité à faire
des choix justes capacité à se calmer
réguler nos émotions quand on est énervé
quand on est provoquée
quand on est en colère ce qui se passe
dans notre cerveau c'est ça on est en
prise directe avec nos émotions notre
mémoire ancienne et nous réaction de
survie
l'attak la fuite ou la sidération et on
est déconnecté de notre empathie de
notre moralité de notre capacité à faire
des choix justes de notre capacité à
réguler nos émotions et parce qu'on est
déconnecté c'est là on peut avoir des
mots blessants
c'est là qu'on peut avoir des actes
violents on peut même devenir
terrorisant pour les autres c'est mon
histoire de dragons tout à l'heure quand
on est comme ça
est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
résoudre un problème de façon sensée
certainement pas quand on est comme ça
on a raison et on va le prouver aux
autres par tous les moyens quitte à les
rabaisser
où est violent bah oui on n'a ni
empathie ni moralité quand on est comme
ça aussi on n'a pas envie de se calmer
on a envie de résoudre le problème là
tout de suite maintenant alors l'outil
de discipline positive à ce moment là
c'est le temps de pause le temps de
pause c'est juste le temps on se donne
pour se reconnecter physiologiquement
alors c'est quoi le temps pour le
pouvoir qu'ont à ce moment là sur notre
santé mentale est extraordinaire la
cigarette l'alcool les écrans la
nourriture
bref tout ce qui prête aux addictions
est un temps de pause trompeur ont
arrêté une grosse fumeuse je peux vous
le dire ça favorise pas du tout une
bonne santé mentale
l'apaisement est illusoire alors le
temps de pause c'est quoi le ton qu'on
prend chacun a sa technique pour se
calmer
ça va être pour certains d'aller
s'isoler d'aller dans sa chambre d'aller
marcher un instant courir se mettre dans
sa bulle
écouter de la musique l'idée c'est
vraiment de se recentrer lever la main
ceux qui pensaient que maintenant que
vous savez ça vous n'allez plus jamais
vous énerver alors malheureusement ou
heureusement reste des êtres humains est
vide et c'est pas que ça arrive plus
jamais l'idée c'est que ça arrive moins
souvent et que plus rapidement on arrive
à se calmer
comme on fait du sport on muscle notre
capacité à nous calmer ça favorise nos
relations
notre bien-être et donc notre santé
mentale
si on ne le fait pas ce qui peut se
passer c'est que notre pensée en revient
à la pensée et la barbe à papa inutile
va réactiver notre émotion et ça on peut
le faire parfois pendant des heures ça
peut durer des jours ça peut durer des
semaines parfois des mois ça peut durer
des années
et le problème c'est que ça nous coûte
en temps et en énergie crée de la pensée
inutile nous coûte en temps et en
énergie
mes amis mes collègues me demande
souvent nadine
tu fais pour faire autant de choses
comment tu fais pour avoir autant
d'énergie autant de temps j'ai tout
simplement réduit drastiquement montant
de création de barbe à papa inutile et
quand ça revient parce que ça revient
toujours
je me pose c'est de question 1 est-ce
que c'est vrai et 2 est ce que c'est
vraiment à ça que j'ai envie d'utiliser
mon temps et mon énergie est très vite
enfin quand j'arrive je bascule dans la
construction de projets ou dans la
création pensé utile comme je suis à la
hauteur
je suis capable j'ai peur et je vais
surmonter ma peur et c'est là que je me
sens bien et c'est ça la santé mentale
muscler votre pensée utile et
constructive
et rappelez à vos amis quand ils font de
la barbe à papa muscler votre capacité à
vous calmer et rappelez à vos amis quand
ils sont comme ça
cherchez actionner sollicité ce pouvoir
qui est en vous c'est pas parce que je
suis en colère que je dois taper c'est
pas parce que je pense que je suis
timide que je dois m'empêcher d'aller
vers les autres
c'est pas parce que je suis blessé que
je dois attaquer c'est parce que vous
prendrez le pouvoir sur votre santé
mentale que vous avancerez un petit pas
à la fois j'étais timide et je m'énerve
encore mais un peu moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]